OKAY. GOOD. OKAY SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE WILL NOW COME
TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON. WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE MEETING
HERE IN THE BUILDING IN ROOM
2200. I ASK THAT ALL MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMITTEE COME FORWARD TO BE
PRESENT SO THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH
A QUORUM, WE WILL BEGIN OUR
HEARING, ABSENT OF QUORUM, WE
HAVE SIX BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA, AND ONE OF THOSE ARE ON
PROPOSED CONSENT, ANNOUNCEMENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1947. THREE OF US
WAS PULLED BY BY THE COMMITTEE
AND ASSEMBLY BILL, 1974.
CONNOLLY WAS PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR. SO WE WILL NOT HAVE
THOSE TODAY. SEE, OKAY, SO WE
HAVE TWO MEMBERS HERE TODAY. WE
WILL BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE AND
WE WILL BE MOVING IN FILE ORDER,
WE HAVE ONE BILL ON THE PROPOSED
CALENDAR CONSENT CALENDAR. WE
WILL HEAR THAT ONCE WE ESTABLISH
OUR QUORUM, UNTIL THEN, WE WILL
HEAR FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR.
HELLO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. BLANCA
RUBIO. WE'LL HAVE YOU PRESENT
ITEM NUMBER ONE, ASSEMBLY BILL
866, AND WE'LL HAVE YOU COME
FORWARD TO THE PODIUM. AND THEN
IF YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES WITH
YOU HERE TODAY, WE'LL HAVE THEM
FIND A SEAT HERE. OKAY THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS,
AB 866 IS A CONTINUATION OF OUR
EFFORTS TO FURTHER PROTECT OUR
FOSTER YOUTH, ESPECIALLY IN THE
FACE OF THE ONGOING OPIOID
CRISIS. JUST LAST YEAR, THE
STATE REVISED RESTRICTIONS ON
FEDERALLY APPROVED OPIOID USE
DISORDER TREATMENT, WHICH CAN BE
ADMINISTERED OUTSIDE OF A
CLINICAL SETTING. THIS ALLOWED
YOUTH 16 YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER
TO SEEK TREATMENT WITHOUT THE
STIGMA OF FEAR OFTEN ASSOCIATED
WITH SEEKING SAID SUPPORT IN
CASE OF OPIOID ADDICTION,
RECEIVING TIMELY AND ACCESSIBLE
TREATMENT IS, WITHOUT
EXAGGERATION, A MATTER OF LIFE
OR DEATH. SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
AB 816 LAST YEAR, OUR COLLEAGUES
REPRESENTING FOSTER YOUTH IN THE
LEGAL SYSTEM HAVE FOUND THAT
THERE IS UNCERTAINTY IN THE
APPLICATION OF THE LAW, LEAVING
FOSTER YOUTH WITHOUT THE SAME
TREATMENT CERTAINTY, CERTAINLY,
CERTAINTY AS THOSE OUTSIDE OF
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM, THESE
SAME YOUTH OFTEN HAVE TRAUMA
HISTORIES THAT HAVE ARISEN FROM
BOTH WITHIN AND OUTSIDE OF THE
SYSTEM, RESULTING IN ESPECIALLY
DANGEROUS ADDICTION
CIRCUMSTANCES. ADDITIONALLY,
MANY OF THESE YOUTHS HAVE
GENERIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL,
GENETIC, AND ENVIRONMENTAL RISK
FACTORS THAT INCREASE THEIR
CHANCE OF SAID ADDICTION AND
OVERDOSE. WHILE IT'S TRAGIC THAT
WE EVEN NEED LEGISLATION SUCH AS
THIS OR ITS PREDECESSOR FOR THAT
MATTER, THE REALITY IS THAT BY
ENSURING FOSTER YOUTH HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE TREATMENTS,
LIVES WOULD BE SAVED BY
CLARIFYING THE ROLE OF COURT
OVERSIGHT IN THESE CASES. THIS
MEASURE PROVIDES CERTAINTY FOR
FOSTER YOUTH WHO COULD BENEFIT
FROM, FROM, AND PROACTIVELY SEEK
MEDICAL ASSISTED TREATMENT JUST
AS OTHERS OUTSIDE OF THE SYSTEM.
I WANT TO REITERATE THIS MEASURE
SIMPLY ENSURES THAT FOSTER YOUTH
CAN RECEIVE THE SAME TREATMENT
AS YOUTH OUTSIDE OF THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM, AS ALREADY ALLOWED
BY CURRENT LAW. THIS MEASURE HAS
A COALITION OF FOSTER YOUTH
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION WITH ME. TODAY, ON
BEHALF OF OUR SPONSOR IS ANN
QUIRK, A POLICY ATTORNEY WITH
CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. BEFORE WE GO TO YOUR
WITNESS, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, I'M
GOING TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SO
WE CAN MOVE FORWARD. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALVARADO. GIL. PRESENT
ALVARADO, GIL. PRESENT.
AQUEBOGUE BLAKE. SPEER. PRESENT
BLAKE. SPEER. PRESENT. HURTADO
MENGIBAR. PRESENT. MENGIBAR
PRESENT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ONE MORE TIME. OCHOA. BOGH HERE
A CHOBOQ HERE. OKAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. SO WE NOW HAVE A QUORUM
, AND WE WILL CONTINUE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT BRIEF INTERRUPTION. WE'LL
MOVE FORWARD WITH YOUR FIRST
WITNESS, PLEASE. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M
ANN QUIRK, POLICY ATTORNEY WITH
CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER. WE'RE THE
LARGEST, CHILDREN'S LEGAL
SERVICES ORGANIZATION IN THE
NATION, ADVOCATING FOR OVER
25,000 YOUTH IN THE DEPENDENCY
SYSTEM IN LOS ANGELES, PLACER
AND SACRAMENTO COUNTIES. WE'RE
PROUD TO SPONSOR AB EIGHT, SIX,
SIX AND ARE GRATEFUL FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO'S
PARTNERSHIP IN ENSURING OLDER
FOSTER YOUTH SUFFERING FROM
OPIOID ADDICTION RECEIVE THE
CARE AND TREATMENT THEY NEED.
IT'S HEARTBREAKING TO LOSE A
TEENAGE CLIENT. WE'VE LOST FAR
TOO MANY TO OVERDOSE AND TO THE
DANGER AND VIOLENCE THAT OFTEN
ACCOMPANIES OPIOID ADDICTION.
ANYONE WHO HAS UP CLOSE
EXPERIENCE WITH ADDICTION EITHER
THEIR OWN OR LOVED ONES, KNOWS
HOW SHORT THAT WINDOW CAN BE.
WHEN SOMEONE IS WILLING TO TAKE
AND ACCEPT HELP, THE COURT
PROCESS DOES NOT MOVE QUICKLY. A
DOCTOR IS REQUIRED TO SUBMIT
PAPERWORK. SOCIAL WORKERS
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT PAPERWORK.
PROPER NOTICE MUST BE GIVEN TO
THE FAMILY, THE TRIBE, EVERYONE
INVOLVED IN THE CASE, DUE
PROCESS MUST BE ENSURED. IT CAN
TAKE WEEKS, EVEN MONTHS, AND WE
DON'T HAVE THAT KIND OF TIME.
THIS BILL WILL CLARIFY FOR OLDER
FOSTER YOUTH CAN GET THE
TREATMENT THEY NEED RIGHT AWAY.
THE CONSEQUENCE OF NOT GETTING
TIMELY ACCESS TO THIS TREATMENT
CAN BE DEVASTATING. THE DRUG
ABUSE CONTINUES. IT JUST MEANS
THE TREATMENT ISN'T THERE AND
ADDITION TO THE RISK OF
OVERDOSE, OPIOID ADDICTION IS
EXPENSIVE. PREDATORS TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
THE DESPERATION, AND THEY
EXPLOIT THEM IN EXCHANGE FOR
PROVIDING DRUGS. GETTING HELP IS
INTIMIDATING. THIS BILL WILL
CLARIFY THAT THE YOUNG PERSON
CAN SEEK HELP FROM THEIR SOCIAL
WORKER, THEIR CASA, THEIR
ATTORNEY, AN ADULT THEY TRUST
WITHOUT REQUIRING THAT THEIR
STRUGGLE WITH ADDICTION BECOME A
PART OF THEIR PERMANENT COURT.
FILE THEY CAN ALSO BE OPEN WITH
THEIR DOCTOR AND LET THEM KNOW
THAT THEY ARE IN FOSTER CARE.
AND SO THEY CAN ENSURE THAT
THEIR TREATMENT PLAN IS TAILORED
TO ACTUALLY MEET THEIR NEEDS. I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO ONCE AGAIN FOR AUTHORING
THIS IMPORTANT AUTHORIZATION AND
HER ONGOING COMMITMENT TO FOSTER
YOUTH, AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SHOW SUPPORT? WE ASK THAT YOU
COME FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE
WITH YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION ONLY. PLEASE GOOD
AFTERNOON. KRISTIN POWELL WITH
THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FOR BHATTACHARJEE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SUSANNA KNIFFEN WITH
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. LIZZIE
KUPTANA HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
JOSH GALLAGHER, ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT, THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ANY LEAD WITNESSES
PRESENT TODAY IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL? ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NONE, WE'LL BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO THE MEMBERS COMMITTEE. I
WILL MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT BEFORE
WE GO INTO THIS. WE HAVE FOUR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
PRESENT, WE, WE DO HAVE A HARD
STOP HERE IN THE NEXT HOUR OR
SO. SO IF OUR FIFTH COMMITTEE
MEMBER DOES NOT NOT MAKE IT TO
COMMITTEE, AND A BILL FAILS, WE
WILL GRANT RECONSIDERATION. SO
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE ALL OF
OUR AUTHORS KNOW THAT. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I JUST WANT
TO MAKE A COMMENT HERE, WE HAVE
REALLY BEEN STRUGGLING WRESTLING
WITH THIS NOTION OF AGE. AND I
NOTICED THAT YOUR BILL ALLOWS 16
YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER THAT CAN
CONSENT TO RECEIVE THESE
MEDICATIONS, I OFTEN GO ON THE
RECORD SAYING, YOU KNOW, RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE VERY DIFFERENT
THAN URBAN CENTERS, AND I WOULD
BE A HYPOCRITE IF I DIDN'T,
BRING THAT SAME NOTION UP HERE.
BUT THE DIFFERENCE IS THAT,
THERE ARE DIFFERENT NEEDS IN
URBAN SETTINGS AND RURAL
SETTINGS, AND PARTICULARLY IN
THE AREA THAT I REPRESENT,
PARENTS ARE VERY PROTECTIVE OF
THAT ABILITY, ME YOU KNOW, ME AS
ONE OF THEIR CHILDREN, AS
DEFINED BY LAW UNDER 18, BEING
ABLE TO MAKE DECISIONS IS THAT A
LEGAL ADULT WOULD. SO I AM GOING
TO LAY OFF THIS BILL, BUT FREE
FROM PREJUDICE, AND, AND, YOU
KNOW, THANK YOU FOR, FOR LOOKING
AT WAYS TO ADDRESS THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR FOSTER
YOUTH, BECAUSE IT'S SO COMPLEX.
AND CALIFORNIA IS SUCH A DIVERSE
AND COMPLEX ECOSYSTEM, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY FOR ME, I WILL LAY
OFF. OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY. SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR BREAKSPEARE. OKAY. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE BEFORE WE TAKE
A VOTE? THANK YOU. YES. I JUST
WANT TO ALSO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HONESTY. I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE, REITERATE THAT, RIGHT
NOW, I DON'T WANT TO CALL THEM
REGULAR KIDS, BUT KIDS THAT ARE
NOT IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
HAVE THAT ABILITY ALREADY TO DO
THAT. AND SO WHAT THIS IS DOING
IS TRYING TO ALIGN THE 16 YEAR
OLD FOSTER KIDS THAT DON'T HAVE
PARENTS, OR AT LEAST THEY YOU
KNOW, SOME OF THESE FOLKS HAVE
ARE IN AND OUT OF THE, YOU KNOW,
ONE FAMILY TO ANOTHER. AND SO
WHAT I WAS THINKING, OR WHAT WE
WERE THINKING IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
MAKE THAT CHOICE AND CARRY IT
WITH THEM BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE A STABLE HOME. AND OF
COURSE, NOT EVERYBODY IS IN THAT
SITUATION. BUT WE'RE TRYING TO
LOOK AFTER THOSE KIDS THAT THAT
DON'T HAVE STABLE PARENTS. AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR HONESTY, BUT
WITH WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE AND THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU FOR CHAMPIONING, LEGISLATION
AND POLICY FOR FOSTER KIDS.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT.
SO WE WILL, ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM ONE AB
866. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. ALVARADO,
GIL. NOT VOTING. OCHOA BOGUE.
NÓ. CHOBOQ. NO. BLAKE. SPEER Ã
BLAKE. SPEER, I HURTADO.
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I OKAY, SO
WE HAVE, EYES. TWO NO'S. ONE. WE
WILL PLACE THIS BILL ON CALL.
THANK YOU. OKAY, SO MOVING ON IN
FILE ORDER. ITEM NUMBER TWO,
ASSEMBLY BILL 922, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WIX WILL ASK THAT YOU
BRING FORWARD ANY WITNESSES THAT
YOU HAVE WITH YOU. PLEASE JOIN
US HERE AT THE FRONT. HAVE TWO
WITNESS SEATS. RIGHT. OKAY. AND
WHEN YOU'RE READY TO PRESENT,
WE'LL HEAR YOUR BILL. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, THE
GOAL OF AB TWO, SORRY, 9 TO 2 IS
TO COMBAT HUNGER AND FOOD
INSECURITY IN CALIFORNIA'S
UNHOUSED COMMUNITIES. THE BILL
WOULD CODIFY A RESTAURANT MEAL
DELIVERY PILOT PROGRAM SERVING
UNHOUSED COMMUNITIES THAT HAS
BEEN SUCCESSFULLY OPERATED IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY, WHICH IS WHERE I
LIVE AND REPRESENT. THIS PILOT
PROGRAM WAS BORN DURING THE
PANDEMIC, WHICH AMPLIFIES THE
SIGNIFICANT NEED TO FEED THE
UNHOUSED AND TO KEEP LOCAL
RESTAURANTS OPEN AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES WORKING. ALAMEDA
COUNTY WANTS TO SHARE AND BUILD
OUT THIS MODEL PROGRAM THAT
SUCCESSFULLY DELIVERED
NUTRITIOUS FOOD WHILE INVESTING
IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES. MADAM
CHAIR, I SHARE YOUR DESIRE TO
SPREAD THIS PROGRAM BEYOND
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND WE HAVE
SPOKEN WITH SANTA CRUZ, SOLANO,
SONOMA, AND SAN BERNARDINO, SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTIES, AND WE
COMMIT TO AMENDING THE BILL TO
ALLOW OTHER COUNTIES TO ACCESS
THIS MODEL AND ANY POTENTIAL
FUNDING UPON APPROPRIATION. IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY, 47% OF
PARTICIPATING RESTAURANTS WERE
OWNED BY BLACK, INDIGENOUS, AND
OTHER PEOPLE OF COLOR AND OR
WOMEN IN TODAY'S ECONOMY, SMALL
RESTAURANT OWNERS ARE STILL
STRUGGLING WITH THE RISING COSTS
AND A TIGHT LABOR MARKET THAT
CHIP AWAY AT ALREADY LOW PROFIT
MARGINS. BY PASSING AB 922, YOU
WILL SIMULTANEOUSLY FEED THOSE
IN NEED, SUPPORT ECONOMIC
STABILITY AND CONTINUE A MODEL
PROGRAM WITH A PROOF OF CONCEPT.
WITH ME ARE TO TESTIFY TODAY IS
CATHY MCDONALD ON BEHALF OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND MARIA
ALDERETE WITH COMMUNITY
KITCHENS. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. WONDERFUL. WE'LL GO
TO OUR WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
YOU'LL EACH GET TWO MINUTES TO
SHARE, PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION IN
DETAIL. THANK YOU. GREAT. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I'LL KICK OFF
KATHY MCDONALD, REPRESENTING THE
COUNTY OF ALAMEDA. VERY PROUD TO
SPONSOR THE LEGISLATION. AS YOU
KNOW, THE HOMELESS RESIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA, WHICH NUMBER, MORE
THAN 170,000 AT ANY GIVEN POINT
IN TIME, DO FACE UNSANITARY
CONDITIONS AND NUMEROUS HEALTH
RISKS FROM WHERE THEY LIVE.
THEY'RE OFTEN ON THE OUTSKIRTS
OF OUR COMMUNITIES, AND THEY'RE
PUSHED INTO FOOD DESERTS WHERE
IT CAN BE VERY DIFFICULT TO GET
ANY FOOD, LET ALONE NUTRITIOUS,
HEALTHY FOOD OR PREPARED MEALS.
THERE IS A CRITICAL GAP IN
SERVICES FOR OUR UNHOUSED ADULTS
WHO REALLY MAKE UP THE PRIMARY
HOMELESS DEMOGRAPHIC. AND FOR
THOSE MEAL OPTIONS THAT DO
EXIST, THEY OFTEN ARE FOCUSED ON
FAST FOOD, NOT ON PREPARED
MEALS. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE FOUND THROUGH RESEARCH
AS WELL IS THAT HOMELESS
RESIDENTS FACE A SIGNIFICANT
BURDEN IN WHICH THEY WALK AT
SOMETIMES 10 TO 15 MILES A DAY
TO GET TO THE SERVICES THAT ARE
OFFERED. SO THIS COULD INCLUDE A
FOOD PANTRY, A SOUP KITCHEN TYPE
OF CONGREGATE MEAL. AND SO FOR
THEM TO TRAVEL ALL OF THIS
DISTANCE TO RECEIVE THESE MEALS,
ALAMEDA COUNTY'S MODEL AND THE
MODEL THAT WE'RE HOPING THIS,
BILL CAN HELP TO PROPAGATE
STATEWIDE, IDEALLY OVER TIME, IS
TO BE ABLE TO BRING THE FOOD TO,
TO THE HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS THAT
THEY STARTED, TO TRY TO FILL
THIS GAP DURING THE PANDEMIC.
THE PREPARED MEALS PROGRAM,
WHICH AB 922 WOULD CREATE, WOULD
ALLOW A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
RESTAURANTS, WHICH, AS YOU'LL
HEAR FROM MY COLLEAGUE, ARE
CONTINUING TO STRUGGLE POST
PANDEMIC. AND IT REALLY BUILDS
ON THE GREAT PLATES PROGRAM THAT
WAS A STATEWIDE PROGRAM 40
COUNTIES PARTICIPATED IN, AS
WELL AS ALAMEDA COUNTY SPECIFIC
EMERGENCY FOOD VENDOR PROGRAM,
WHICH TARGETED HOMELESS SHUT IN
SENIORS AND COVID PATIENTS
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THEY WERE
ABLE TO WORK WITH 130 LOCAL
RESIDENT RESTAURANTS AND DELIVER
THE 5 MILLION MEALS TO RESIDENTS
IN 18 MONTHS. THROUGH THAT
PARTNERSHIP, THE ECONOMIC RIPPLE
EFFECT OF THIS PROGRAM WOULD
ALSO BE SIGNIFICANT, EVERY
DOLLAR SPENT IN CALIFORNIA'S
RESTAURANTS CONTRIBUTES $2.09 TO
THE STATE ECONOMY. AND SO THE
PASSAGE OF AB 922 AND WE AGREE
WITH THE COMMENTS REGARDING
ENSURING THAT OTHER COUNTIES ARE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE, THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO FEED THOSE IN NEED
AND SUPPORT STRUGGLING SMALL
RESTAURANT OWNERS AT THE SAME
TIME, AND REALLY CREATE AN
OVERALL POSITIVE IMPACT. YOU
HAVE REACHED YOUR TWO MINUTES,
SO I'LL JUST ASK THAT YOU WRAP
UP. I WAS JUST GOING TO ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. WE'LL MOVE
TO SECOND WITNESS. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS, MY
NAME IS MARIA ALDEROTY, AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNITY KITCHENS. DURING THE
PANDEMIC, WE AND OTHER VENDORS
PARTNERED WITH ALAMEDA COUNTY TO
PROVIDE THESE 5 MILLION MEALS.
THE PROGRAM PROVIDED MUCH NEEDED
FUNDING FOR FEEDING OUR
UNHOUSED. AND AFTER THE PANDEMIC
ENDED, IT REALLY BROUGHT TO
LIGHT THAT THIS WAS A
SIGNIFICANT GAP IN THE CURRENT,
FOOD SECURITY WORK IN OUR IN OUR
COUNTY AND WITHIN OUR PUBLIC
BENEFIT SYSTEM THROUGH AB 922.
WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
OUR UNHOUSED DODD AND DRIVE
DOLLARS TO MORE THAN THE 130
RESTAURANTS THAT PROVIDED MEALS
DURING THIS TIME, BUT ALSO TO
REALLY SUPPORT THE HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING OF OUR UNHOUSED.
BEING UNHOUSED CAN TAKE UP TO 30
YEARS OFF OF SOMEONE'S LIFE, AND
SO WE FEEL THESE MEALS ARE
REALLY CRITICAL TO GET OUT, OUT,
BUT WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY IS BUILD A
MEAL PLUS PROGRAM. SO WE'RE NOT
JUST PROVIDING A NUTRITIOUS MEAL
TO HELP SUPPORT THEIR HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING. WE'RE PAIRING THAT
WITH OTHER SERVICES, WHETHER
IT'S CALFRESH ENROLLMENT. AND IN
THIS CASE, WE WOULD WANT TO WORK
WITH OTHER HOUSING, COMMUNITY
GROUPS TO HELP GET PEOPLE OFF
THE STREET. SO IN PASSING AB
922, YOU WILL SIMULTANEOUSLY
FEED THOSE IN NEED AND SUPPORT
THESE BUSINESSES FOR EVEN A
WIDER ECONOMIC STABILITY. IT'S
REALLY TRIPLE BENEFITS. YOU'RE
FEEDING THE UNHOUSED, YOU'RE
SUPPORTING INDEPENDENT
RESTAURANTS, WHICH ARE IN TURN
SUPPORT EATING LOCAL JOBS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
I URGE YOU TO PASS AB 922. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. AT THIS TIME, WE'LL
HEAR FROM MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB 922
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SHARE THEIR
POSITION, NAME AND AFFILIATION,
PLEASE. JOSH GAGER, ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC OR LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL? I'D
LIKE TO BE HEARD. OKAY. SEEING
NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SHARE THEIR
OPPOSITION. OKAY SEEING NONE, I
WILL BRING THE CONVERSATION BACK
TO OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? WITH THE
BILL, WHEN APPROPRIATE. ALL
RIGHT. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR, ASSEMBLYWOMAN,
WE HAVEN'T HAD YOU HERE IN OUR
COMMITTEE BEFORE, AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY I'M A BIG FAN OF
YOUR YOUR WORK AND THE HISTORY
THAT YOU HAVE DONE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, IT'S BEEN
TREMENDOUS. AND, YOU KNOW,
BEFORE FINDING MYSELF HERE, YOU
KNOW, AS KIND OF LIKE A YOUNG
POLITICAL ACTIVIST ORGANIZER, I
VERY MUCH SAW THE WORK THAT YOU
WERE DOING NATIONWIDE AND HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND, SAY THAT
YOU'VE HAD AN INFLUENCE ON, ON
ON HOW MY WORLDVIEW AND MY
IDEOLOGIES, THIS BILL, AS I, AS
I READ THROUGH IT, REALLY RAISED
SOME QUESTIONS FOR ME. AND SO
I'M HOPING THAT YOU CAN ADDRESS
SOME OF YOUR CLOSING, ONE, THIS
IS A VERY SPECIFIC COUNTY BILL.
SO OF OUR 52 COUNTIES, IT ONLY
IMPACTS ONE COUNTY, WHICH, YOU
KNOW, I THINK, YOU KNOW, WELL,
WELL MET ALAMEDA COUNTY HAS A
VERY LARGE POPULATION, AS WELL
AS AN UNHOUSED POPULATION. BUT I
REALLY STRUGGLE WITH WHY TO HAVE
A STATEWIDE LEGISLATIVE ACTION
FOR JUST ONE COUNTY WHERE THE
COUNTY HAS A FULL BOARD AND
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND, AND
THE CITIES HAVE THEIR INDIVIDUAL
GOVERNMENTS AS WELL. IT'S LIKE,
WHY WE WOULD NEED TO TAKE A
LEGISLATIVE ACTION, THE SECOND
THING THAT COMES UP FOR ME IS
THIS NOTION OF CATERING,
CATERING FOOD. BRINGING FOOD TO
A PLACE WHERE NOT EVEN OUR
WORKING POOR GET THAT SERVICE.
RIGHT. YOU KNOW, I, I REMEMBER,
YOU KNOW, AS A, AS A YOUNG
MOTHER RAISING MY KIDS AND
KNOWING THAT, YOU KNOW, FRIDAY'S
WAS LITTLE CAESARS PIZZA DAY AND
THAT IF I COULD JUST, YOU KNOW,
PUT $10 ASIDE, YOU KNOW, I COULD
GO AND PICK THAT PIZZA UP AND
BRING IT. BUT IF I GOT DELIVERY,
I WOULD HAVE TO COME UP FOR
ABOUT 15, 20 BUCKS IN THOSE
TIMES. RIGHT? SO THERE IS A
LUXURY IN GETTING FOOD DELIVERED
TO YOUR DOMICILE. AND, THIS BILL
IS NOT ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO
TRANSPORTATION OR NOT, BUT I DO
KNOW THAT URBAN SETTINGS,
PARTICULARLY ALAMEDA COUNTY, HAS
A PLETHORA OF NONPROFITS AND
CHURCHES AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
THAT PROVIDE MEALS AND HAVE A
COMPASSION AND COMPASSIONATE,
EMPATHETIC, INTERACTION WITH THE
UNHOUSED. SO I'M PERPLEXED ON
THIS BILL BECAUSE OF THAT AS
WELL. IT'S LIKE, WHY? WHY WOULD
WE WANT CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS TO
PROVIDE A CATERING SERVICE TO
THE UNHOUSED IN ALAMEDA WHEN,
YOU KNOW, IT'S SUCH A LUXURY TO
HAVE THAT DOOR SERVICE RIGHT,
AND THEN LAST BUT NOT LEAST, AND
PLEASE, WE COULD EITHER ADDRESS
IT IN YOUR CLOSING OR WE CAN
HAVE A BRIEF CONVERSATION ON IS.
I ALSO NOTICED THAT YOU DON'T
REPRESENT ALAMEDA COUNTY, I DO
BERKELEY AND PIEDMONT AND PARTS
OF OAKLAND. PARTS OF OAKLAND.
OKAY. I WANTED I WANTED THAT
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE I WAS A
LITTLE CONFUSED BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU, YOU REPRESENT THE HEART OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY, YOU KNOW,
AND I CAN SEE LIKE RICHMOND
REALLY LIKE WANTING TO GET
BEHIND THIS BILL AND SUPPORT YOU
. SO, THAT WAS THE OTHER PIECE
OF CONFUSION FOR ME. SO, YOU
KNOW, I'D LOVE TO KIND OF HEAR
YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND, AND KIND
OF SEE WHERE, WHERE MY MIND GOES
WITH IT. SURE. ABSOLUTELY. AND I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS AND THE
OPENING, COMMENTS WERE VERY
KIND. WERE BOTH DAUGHTERS OF THE
SIERRAS. SO, I VERY FAMILIAR
WITH, WITH YOUR DISTRICT BECAUSE
I COME FROM PLACER COUNTY, BUT,
YOU KNOW, IN TERMS OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU ASKED, YOU
KNOW, ONE, WE DID THIS IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY, AND IT WORKED.
RIGHT. AND SO I THINK THE GOAL
HERE, THE GOAL WOULD BE TO GO
STATEWIDE, BUT TO START WITH A
PILOT PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
ACTUALLY WORKING, THAT THE STATE
HAS THE ABILITY TO ACTUALLY DO
THIS TYPE OF WORK, AND PUT IN
STATUE AND WRAP ITS ARMS AROUND
A PILOT PROGRAM. YOU KNOW, AS
I'VE SORT OF UNDERTAKEN MY
LEGISLATIVE CAREER, I'M NOW SORT
OF SIX YEARS IN, I'M LIKE
LEGISLATIVELY MIDDLE AGED. YOU
KNOW, IT'S TAKEN ME A MINUTE TO
UNDERSTAND ALL THE THINGS SINCE
I'VE GOTTEN HERE. BUT ONE THING
THAT I'VE NOTICED IN MY TIME IN
THE LEGISLATURE IS REALLY THE
VALUE OF PILOT PROGRAMS, SO THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING, ESPECIALLY IN
THE CURRENT ECONOMIC TIMES. SO
BIG THAT, YOU KNOW, WE EITHER
MAKE MISTAKES, WE RUSH THINGS,
WE GO TOO FAST. THE PILOT
PROGRAMS REALLY ALLOW US TO
LEARN FROM OUR EXPERIENCE, TO
MODIFY, TO MAKE BETTER, SO THAT
WHEN IF WE DO DECIDE TO GO, YOU
KNOW, TRULY STATEWIDE AND SERVE
ALL 58 COUNTIES, WE HAVE A REAL
PROOF OF CONCEPT ON HOW TO DO
THAT AND HOW TO DO THAT
EFFECTIVELY SO THAT WE GET OUR
TAXPAYERS GET A GOOD ROI ON THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE DOING.
AND I THINK AND I LOOK AT THE
SAME THING WITH HOUSING AND A
LOT OF OTHER THINGS, WE WORK ON,
WE HAVE TO GIVE OUR TAXPAYERS A
STRONG ROI. YOU KNOW, THEY'RE
THE ONES FUNDING THIS WORK, AND
SO ENSURING THERE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES THAT
THERE'S PROOF OF CONCEPT THAT WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S WORKING, YOU
KNOW, WE CHOSE ALAMEDA COUNTY IN
PART BECAUSE WE DID THIS
ESSENTIALLY IN THE IN THE
PANDEMIC. I LIVE IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY. I REPRESENT PARTS OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND PARTS OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. SO I HAVE
BOTH COUNTIES IN MY DISTRICT,
BUT WE'RE CERTAINLY OPEN TO
OTHER COUNTIES. YOU KNOW, IN AN
IDEAL WORLD, WE'D HAVE 58
COUNTIES IN THIS, PROGRAM, AND
AGAIN, I THINK THAT WOULD BE THE
GOAL DOWN THE ROAD, WE'RE
DEFINITELY WILLING TO ADD OTHER
COUNTIES AS WELL. I THINK IT'S
ALWAYS A AND I SAY THIS AS THE
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR NOW
FIGURING OUT WHAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY AFFORD TO DO IS THE
QUESTION. AND THAT'S THE REAL
STRUGGLE IN THE CURRENT
ENVIRONMENT, BUT WE HAVE NEED
ACROSS THE STATE, WE HAVE LOW
INCOME FOLKS IN OUR URBAN AREAS,
IN OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES, YOU
KNOW, IN OUR EXURBAN AREAS OR
SUBURBAN COMMUNITIES, IN TERMS
OF THE ACTUAL PROGRAM ITSELF, I
THINK WHAT WE'VE REALIZED DURING
THE PANDEMIC DOING THIS PROGRAM,
AND I THINK WHAT OUR WITNESSES
TESTIFIED TO IS IT'S FILLING A
NEED. I MEAN, WE HAVE FOOD
INSECURITY WITH OUR UNHOUSED
POPULATION. IT'S SUCH A HIGH
RATE, YOU DO HAVE FOLKS THAT ARE
WALKING TEN, 15 MILES PER DAY TO
GET TO FOOD. THESE ARE FOLKS
THAT DON'T HAVE RESOURCES,
ANYTHING WE CAN DO AND THE DUAL
PARTNERSHIP OF HELPING OUR, OUR,
OUR RESTAURANTS, OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES IS A NICE ADDED
BENEFIT BECAUSE MANY OF THEM ARE
STRUGGLING AS WELL, BUT REALLY
THE GOAL HERE IS, IS TO PROVIDE
A SOLUTION, YOU KNOW, AND I'M,
I'M ALL ABOUT SOLUTIONS AND WHAT
WORKS, AND WORKING WITH
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PEOPLE TO DO
THAT, AND BRINGING FORTH, YOU
KNOW, WE SHOULD ALL BE MEASURED
ON THE OUTCOMES WE AS ELECTED
SHOULD BE MEASURED ON THE
OUTCOMES. AND WE'VE SEEN A
POSITIVE OUTCOME WITH THE
PROGRAM LIKE THIS. WE WANT TO
CONTINUE THAT AT THE STATE
LEVEL, START WITH ALAMEDA AND
OTHER COUNTIES AND SEE IF WE
CAN, IN BETTER ECONOMIC TIMES,
EXPAND IT STATEWIDE. BUT AGAIN,
WITH PROOF OF CONCEPT, KNOWING
WHAT WORKS BEST AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. YES,
SENATOR BLAKESPEAR, I WAS I'M
PLANNING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND BUT THE THING THAT RUNS
THROUGH MY MIND AGAIN AND AGAIN
THAT I JUST WANTED TO BRING UP
IS JUST MY OVERALL CONCERN ABOUT
WASTE AND TRASH. AND SO, YOU
KNOW, A LOT OF IF DELIVERED FOOD
CAN CREATE A LOT OF WASTE. AND
THERE'S, YOU KNOW, WHAT EXACTLY
WOULD WE DO ABOUT THAT AND HOW
SUSTAINABLE IS THE PACKAGING
AROUND IT? AND JUST, YOU KNOW,
THINKING THROUGH EXACTLY WHAT IT
MEANS TO HAVE THAT HAPPEN? YEAH,
I MEAN, I THINK THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT POINT. I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU ALL WANT TO OPINE ON THAT
WITH ANY OF THE EXPERIENCES IN
THE PROGRAM IN ALAMEDA COUNTY.
YEAH I WILL SAY THAT WE JUST GOT
A GRANT FROM STOP WASTE WHERE WE
ARE LOOKING TO PILOT REUSABLE
CONTAINERS, WE HAVE THE ABILITY
WHEN WE DROP OFF FOOD TO ALSO
PICK UP. SO THAT'S DEFINITELY AN
AREA THAT IS OF CONCERN OF OURS
THAT WE WANT TO EMBED IN THE
PROGRAM. AND ALSO JUST SAY, AND
I SHOULD HAVE, I THINK SAID THIS
AS WELL, WHEN WHAT'S YOUR
QUESTIONS? HOPEFULLY OUR THIS
PROGRAM NEVER HAS TO EXIST. YOU
KNOW, I MEAN WE SHOULD BE
BUILDING THE HOUSING WE NEED TO
AND PROVIDING THE SERVICES WE
NEED AND THE, THE WORKFORCE
TRAINING AND ALL THE OTHER
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO. SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO DO THIS
WORK. BUT IN THE END OF THE DAY,
RIGHT NOW, IT IS A NEED THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO FILL, EVEN
THOUGH THERE'S CONCERNS AROUND
SOME OF THESE ISSUES. BUT, YOU
KNOW, I THINK WITH THOUGHTFUL
PARTNERSHIP, I THINK THAT'S ALSO
WHY TO YOUR QUESTION, SENATOR,
WHY A PILOT PROGRAM, I THINK IS
IMPORTANT? BECAUSE IF YOU CAN
INFUSE THAT INTO THE PILOT
PROGRAM OF SPECIFIC PROTOCOL
AROUND WASTE, THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT THEN AGAIN, WE COULD TAKE
STATEWIDE SO THAT WE'RE AGAIN
DOING PROOF OF CONCEPT. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT. SO I THINK
I DID HEAR YOU SAY THAT THAT
WE'VE ATTEMPTED THIS PROGRAM
BEFORE AND IT WORKED, WAS THAT A
REFERENCE DURING THE PANDEMIC.
PANDEMIC? YEAH RIGHT. SO I THINK
FOR ME THAT THAT IS ENOUGH FOR
ME TO STAY OFF THE BILL, BEING
THAT I, I REALIZED DURING THE
PANDEMIC WE HAD TO HAVE CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T
GO INTO A STORE AND GET FOOD.
AND I THINK THERE WAS A CRITICAL
NEED FOR US TO SUPPORT OUR
RESTAURANTS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND YOU KNOW, WE
WERE MAKING THINGS HAPPEN WITH
FEDERAL DOLLARS, RIGHT? WE WERE
SHOWERED WITH FEDERAL DOLLARS,
AND NOW WE'RE IN A STATE, A
CRITICAL FINANCIAL STATE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. VÀ, I DO RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE'S AN APPROPRIATION
ATTACHED TO THIS UPON
APPROPRIATION AND WE'RE NOT A
FISCAL BODY. WE'RE A POLICY BODY
, FOR ME, IT'S JUST IT'S
DIFFICULT TO MAKE THE
CORRELATION ON THAT. IF IT
WORKED DURING COVID OR DURING
THE PANDEMIC, IT WOULD ALSO WORK
DURING MORE FRUITFUL TIMES, BUT
I DO WANT TO I DO WANT TO SEE
WHERE THIS BILL GOES BECAUSE AS
I PILOT PROGRAMS FOR ME ARE VERY
EXCITING TO SEE HOW DO THEY WORK
IN URBAN CENTERS AND HOW WE CAN
DUPLICATE THEM IN RURAL AREAS,
SO I WILL LAY OFF THE BILL AGAIN
FREE OF PREJUDICE. WE ALL MAKE
OUR OWN DECISIONS IN THIS
COMMITTEE, AND IF THE BILL
SHOULD NOT PASS, WE WILL PUT IT
ON CALL AND GRANT
RECONSIDERATION IF WE NEED TO
CLOSE THE ROLL. OKAY. THANK YOU.
YEAH, I APPRECIATE THAT. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
FROM EVERYONE ELSE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SO I THINK WE
HAVE A MOTION. SENATOR MENGIBAR,
MOVE THE BILL. ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM TWO AB
922. MOTION IS Dð. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO, GIL. NOT VOTING.
AQUEBOGUE. NO OCHOA. BOGH. NO.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. HURTADO. MENGIBAR A
MENGIBAR. AYE. AND THE EYES ARE
TWO NO'S ARE ONE. WE WILL PUT
THIS BILL ON CALL. THANK YOU.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE. I'M SORRY TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE, ASSEMBLY BILL 1948.
RENDON AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS, WILL YOU
BE PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RENDON? OKAY.
WE'LL ASK YOU TO COME TO THE
PODIUM. AND IF YOU DO, YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES WITH YOU HERE
TODAY, RIGHT? WE'LL HAVE THEM
COME HERE, HERE TO THE TABLE.
GET SITUATED. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS WERE. I SEE YOU AND
YOU'RE NEXT. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. WE WILL HEAR ASSEMBLY BILL
1948 WHEN YOU'RE READY. WELL
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS. AB 1948 REMOVES THE
JANUARY 1ST, 2025 SUNSET DATE ON
AB 728 OF 2019 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO. SO THIS BILL
ALLOWS MULTIDISCIPLINARY
PERSONNEL, TEAMS OR MDTS AND
AGENCIES CONNECTED TO MDTS IN
SELECT COUNTIES TO EXCHANGE THE
PERSONAL INFORMATION OF
INDIVIDUALS IDENTIFIED AS BEING
AT IMMINENT RISK OF BECOMING
UNHOUSED. AND THIS INFORMATION
SHARING FACILITATES EARLY
INTERVENTION WITH COUNTY
SERVICES AND PREVENTS NEW AND
REOCCURRING INCIDENCES OF
HOMELESSNESS. AB 1948 WILL
INDEFINITELY EXTEND THE
AVAILABILITY OF CRITICAL
INTERVENTION AND ASSISTANCE, AND
ALLOW THESE COUNTIES TO STOP
HOMELESSNESS BEFORE IT CAN
OCCUR, TAKING A PROACTIVE
APPROACH HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS MARTHA
GUERRERA. ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, MR. REIRA, FOR BEING
HERE. WE'LL GIVE YOU TWO MINUTES
TO PRESENT ON THIS BILL AND
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS, MARTHA
GUERRERO, REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND I THANK SPEAKER
MARIA RENDON AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO FOR BEING CHAMPIONS ON
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. THIS MEASURE
WOULD ALLOW US TO CONTINUE A
DATA SHARING AGREEMENT THAT
ENHANCES COORDINATION AND
FACILITATES NO WRONG DOOR
APPROACH FOR CLIENTS WHO ARE AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS. IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY, IT'S THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES HOMELESS PREVENTION
UNIT THAT UTILIZES THESE DATA
SHARING AGREEMENTS CONNECTING
PEOPLE WITH RESOURCES FOR THEIR
HOUSING NEEDS. AND IT HAS
DEMONSTRATED SUCCESS FOR 86% OF
THE PARTICIPANTS IDENTIFIED
SUCCESSFULLY SECURING THE
HOUSING UPON EXIT FROM THE
PROGRAM. L.A. COUNTY'S POINT IN
TIME COUNT HAS IDENTIFIED 75,000
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS ON ANY
GIVEN NIGHT, A 9% INCREASE FROM
THE PRIOR COUNT, RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY THAT
FOR EVERY 207 ANGELENOS WHO EXIT
HOMELESSNESS EVERY DAY, ANOTHER
227 FALL INTO IT PREVENTS IN
STEMMING THE FLOW OF PEOPLE INTO
HOMELESS MUST BE A COMPONENT OF
ANY EFFECTIVE HOMELESSNESS
STRATEGY. AB 1948 PROVIDES AN
INNOVATIVE RESOURCE TO NAVIGATE
THE COMPLICATED HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS SERVICES, AND FOR
THESE REASONS, I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT, PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE, NAME, AFFILIATION
AND YOUR POSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON. JOSH GAGA, ON BEHALF
OF THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND VENTURA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, BOTH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
JARED MOSS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF LONG BEACH SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, NICOLE WATERMAN, ON
BEHALF OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
AND THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ANY OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL 1948? ALL RIGHT.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
DO WE HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL THAT
WOULD LIKE TO BE HEARD? OKAY.
SEEING NONE, ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL, PLEASE COME FORWARD. ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE, WE'LL MOVE
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
? OKAY. ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION? I'LL MOVE. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR BLAKESBERG MOVES THE
BILL, ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? WELL,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR,
INTEREST IN THIS BILL AND YOUR
SUPPORT. AND I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ASSISTANT WILL CALL THE ROLL NOW
. FILE ITEM FIVE AB 1948. MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. ALVARADO, GIL Ã.
ALVARADO, GIL. AYE XIAOBO A
AKABOGU. AYE BLAKE. SPEER A
BLAKE. SPEER, AYE. HURTADO
MENGIBAR. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE
OKAY, SO WE HAVE FOUR EYES, THAT
BILL IS OUT. WE'RE NOT DOING ANY
CALL ANYMORE. NO. OKAY, THAT
BILL IS OUT. CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. BUT THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHT, ASSEMBLY MEMBERS,
WE ARE READY FOR YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO BE HEARING ITEM NUMBER
SIX, ASSEMBLY BILL 2477. WE'LL
INVITE YOUR WITNESSES TO COME
FORWARD. THANK YOU. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS AB 2477 WILL
UPLIFT OUR YOUTH BY ALLOWING
THEM TO TRANSITION FROM FOSTER
CARE INTO ADULTHOOD WITH THE
CHANCE TO GROW THE BEST
FINANCIAL SAFETY NET POSSIBLE.
EXISTING LAW STATES THAT YOUTH
IN FOSTER CARE CAN ONLY SAVE UP
TO $10,000, SHOULD THEIR SAVINGS
SURPASS THAT AMOUNT, YOUTH MAY
UNDERGO A REDETERMINATION
ASSESSMENT AND POTENTIALLY LOSE
THEIR BENEFITS DUE TO INCOME OR
RESOURCE INELIGIBILITY. WHILE
MANY FOSTER YOUTH NEVER
ACCUMULATE THAT MUCH IN SAVINGS,
SOME DO, AND HAVING A FINANCIAL
SAFETY NET IS SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD WANT THESE KIDS TO HAVE,
AND WE SHOULD WANT THEM TO BUILD
TO HELP WITH THIS PROBLEM, NEW
GUIDELINES ISSUED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
HAVE CHANGED HOW THE COUNTIES
SHOULD LOOK AT EXISTING LAW, BY
ALLOWING FOSTER YOUTH TO SAVE
MORE THAN 10,000 WITHOUT
WORRYING ABOUT LOSING THEIR
SUPPORT IN FOSTER CARE. HOWEVER,
BECAUSE THIS IMPORTANT POLICY
CLARIFICATION HAS NOT BEEN
CODIFIED IN STATUTE, BUSY
CASEWORKERS WHO ARE UNAWARE OF
THE NUANCE OF THE POLICY CHANGE
STILL CITE THE $10,000 SAVINGS
CAP AS A TRIGGER FOR
REDETERMINATION OF THEIR
ELIGIBILITY FOR BENEFITS. AB
2477 CLARIFIES AMBIGUITIES BY
ALLOWING LINING STATE LAW WITH
RECENT DEPARTMENTAL GUIDANCE,
REMOVING ANY SUGGESTION THAT
YOUTH CANNOT ACCUMULATE CASH
ASSETS WHILE THEY'RE IN FOSTER
CARE. LGBTQ PLUS YOUTH AND
CHILDREN OF COLOR ARE
OVERREPRESENTED IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM DUE TO GREATER RATES
OF FAMILY REJECTION AND SYSTEMIC
INEQUALITY. SO THIS IS A BILL
ABOUT INCREASING FINANCIAL
SECURITY AND EQUITY FOR ALL OUR
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE, AND ABOUT
THE LEGISLATURE'S DUTY TO
SUPPORT MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS
UNDER OUR CARE. WITH ME TODAY
ARE KIM LEWIS, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH,
AND KRISTEN POWER WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS,
BOTH SPONSORS OF THE BILL, TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
AND TO ASSIST WITH QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE.
WE'LL GIVE YOU EACH TWO MINUTES
TO PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE READY,
YOUR NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION. AND
WE'D LOVE TO HEAR FROM YOU.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR. KIM
LEWIS, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH.
PLEASED TO CO-SPONSOR THIS BILL.
AND ONE OF OUR STRATEGIES IS
AROUND PREVENTING THE NUMBER OF
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE ENTERING
HOMELESSNESS. AND THIS BILL
ALLOWS US TO DO SO. A RECENT CAL
YOUTH STUDY CITED THAT 25% OF
YOUNG PEOPLE EXITING FOSTER CARE
HAD EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS
UPON LEAVING CARE, AND WE KNOW
THAT FINANCIAL CAPABILITY IS
IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE TRANSITIONING TO
ADULTHOOD, BUT IT'S ALSO VERY
CRITICAL FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
EXITING FOSTER CARE WHO HAVE
ALREADY FACED MANY NUMEROUS
OTHER CHALLENGES AND ARE
EXPECTED TO IMMEDIATELY MANAGE
THEIR FINANCES AND BECOME
SELF-SUFFICIENT. YOUTH WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED THESE FOSTER CARE
ALSO HAVE, GREATER ECONOMIC
HARDSHIPS THAT LIKE NOT HAVING
THE ABILITY TO HAVE MONEY FOR
HOUSING DEPOSITS, BEING ABLE TO
PAY THEIR RENT, OR TO EVEN BUY A
CAR SO THEY CAN GET TO SCHOOL OR
TO WORK. AND MANY FAMILIES,
YOUNG ADULTS HAVE PARENTS,
SIBLINGS OR SOME OTHER FAMILY
MEMBER WHO CAN HELP THEM WHEN
THEY NEED ASSISTANCE, AND A
STRONG AND SECURE SAFETY NET CAN
BE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
CRISIS BEING RESOLVED OR TURNING
INTO A CHRONIC STRESSOR. SO
REALLY, A STRONG FINANCIAL
SAFETY NET REALLY IMPROVES THE
FINANCIAL RESILIENCE OF OUR
YOUTH TO TAKE ON LIFE WITH MORE
CONFIDENCE AND LESS STRESS. AND
AB 2477 IS A SIMPLE BUT
EFFECTIVE MEASURE TO HELP OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE THRIVE AS THEY EXIT
FOSTER CARE AND DOESN'T HINDER
THEIR ABILITY TO SAVE FOR THEIR
FUTURE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON,
KRISTEN POWER WITH THE ALLIANCE
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZUBIATE DID A
TERRIFIC JOB OF EXPLAINING THE
BILL. SO I JUST WANT TO PUT A
FACE ON WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WITH THIS ISSUE, I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO SHARE A STORY ABOUT ONE
OF OUR CLIENTS. HER NAME IS
ALYSSA. SHE'S A SINGLE MOTHER OF
TWO. SHE JUST RECENTLY EXITED
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AT THE
AGE OF 21. SHE HAS STRUGGLED TO
MAINTAIN STABLE HOUSING, CHILD
CARE AND EMPLOYMENT, AND SHE WAS
NOT ABLE TO SAVE UP TO THAT
REACH THE ABILITY TO HAVE THAT
FINANCIAL SAFETY NET. WHILE SHE
WAS IN CARE TO HELP SUPPORT HER
THROUGH THIS TRANSITION. SO AS
YOU'RE LISTENING TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ZUBIATE BE THINKING ABOUT
ALYSSA AND HOW THIS COULD AFFECT
HER AND HER SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION, I ALSO WANTED TO
JUST MENTION A CALL I GOT
RECENTLY FROM A SMALL URBAN,
RURAL COUNTY, IT WAS A COUNTY
CASEWORKER SEEKING GUIDANCE AS
THE COUNTY WAS WORKING WITH A
YOUNG PERSON WHO HAD RECEIVED A
TRIBAL SETTLEMENT, AND THAT
TRIBAL SETTLEMENT MEANT THAT
THEY HAD EXCEEDED THAT $10,000
CAP, AND THEY WERE MOVING TO
EXIT THE YOUTH FROM CARE. SO I
WAS ABLE TO CITE THE GUIDANCE
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MENTIONED.
BUT OF COURSE, IT WOULD
STRENGTHEN OUR OVERALL ABILITY
TO MAKE THIS NOTATION IN STATE
LAW. AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE ASKING
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO BOTH OF YOU
FOR BEING HERE. ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT OF THE BILL?
PLEASE MOVE FORWARD. YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
ONLY. PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON.
REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAND POVERTY
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR VÀ
BHATTACHARJEE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
LIZZIE KUTSUNA HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND QUIRKY CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, SUSANNA KNIFFEN. WITH
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE'LL NOW GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO, LEAD WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO COME FORWARD
AND BE HEARD. OKAY. SEEING NONE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION OF ASSEMBLY BILL
2477, PLEASE COME FORWARD. OKAY.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS? SENATOR OCHOA, THANK
YOU, MEMBER ZUBER, FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE FORWARD. I'M
ACTUALLY REALLY GRATEFUL FOR
THIS BILL. I'M A HUGE ADVOCATE
FOR, FINANCIAL LITERACY AS WELL
AS SAVINGS. I THINK CULTURALLY,
IT'S VERY HARD IN CALIFORNIA TO
BE ABLE TO SAVE ANY MONEY. AND I
HEAR IT FROM EVEN OUR SENIORS
WHO DON'T QUALIFY FOR MANY
SERVICES BECAUSE THEY OWN A
HOME. BUT THAT IS ALL THEY HAVE,
SO WHEN I SEE THIS FORWARD AND
KNOWING THAT MANY OF OUR KIDS
DON'T HAVE THAT SUPPORT SYSTEM
AROUND THEM, KIDS, I SHOULD SAY
YOUNG ADULTS TOO, WHICH, BY THE
WAY, I DO HAVE A QUESTION. WHAT
IS THE EXIT AGE FOR FOSTER YOUTH
? ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
. THE AGE TO EXIT IS EITHER 18
OR 21, SO 18 IS THE AGE AT WHICH
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE EXIT FOSTER
CARE. IF YOU'RE IN FOSTER CARE
AT THE AGE OF 18, YOU'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE, AND THAT ALLOWS YOU TO
STAY IN FOR THAT ADDITIONAL
THREE YEARS UP TO THE AGE OF 21,
21, $10,000 IS NOT A LOT OF
MONEY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. QUITE FRANKLY. AND
IT'S ONE OF THE CONCERNS WHY ON
MANY FRONTS, I HAVE ACTUALLY
BEEN AN ADVOCATE TO EITHER HAVE
PEOPLE BE ABLE TO WORK, FOR
INSTANCE, WHEN YOU'RE
INCARCERATED, SO THAT WHEN YOU
LEAVE, YOU'RE ABLE TO HAVE SOME
SORT OF A NEST EGG IN ORDER TO
GO TO, INTO OUR COMMUNITIES. BUT
I THINK IN THIS IN, IN THIS
PERSPECTIVE, I'M ACTUALLY A
HUGE, HUGE PROPONENT OF, OF WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO. AND I'M
GRATEFUL THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE
YOUTH THAT ARE WILLING TO WORK
AND HAVE THE DISCIPLINE TO
ACTUALLY SAVE. AND WE SHOULD DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO COMMEND
THEM AND TO HELP THEM AS THEY
EXIT THE SYSTEM. SO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD. THANK YOU. IS THAT A
MOTION? SENATOR CHOBOQ? ALL
RIGHT. WE HAVE A MOTION. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH, SO
WE HAVE A MOTION, ON ASSEMBLY
BILL 2477, ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FILE. ITEM SIX, AB
2477. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO GIL, I ALVARADO. GIL I
AKOBO. AKOBO I BLAKE. SPEER.
BLAKE. SPEER I HURTADO. MENGIBAR
I MENGIBAR I EYES ARE FOUR NOES
ZERO. AND I'VE BEEN TOLD WE WILL
PUT THIS ON CALL AND HAPPY PRIDE
DAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
NOW MOVE TO OUR NEXT ITEM, ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN, ASSEMBLY BILL 2620
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BANES. AND I
SEE SHE'S READY AND PRESENT.
OKAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL ASK
YOU JUST TO INVITE YOUR GUESTS.
YOUR WITNESSES, TO COME TO THE
TABLE. OKAY. I DID MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT EARLIER. WE HAVE
FOUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE
TODAY. WE ARE MISSING ONE, IN
THE EVENT THAT WE, ARE NOT. YOU
DO NOT GET THE VOTES IN THE
MAJORITY. WE WILL PUT THE
MEASURE ON CALL. BUT BEING THAT
YOUR BILL IS FOR THE LAST OF OUR
, OF OUR FILE ORDER TODAY, WE
WILL PROBABLY WRAP UP AROUND
FIVE. WE WILL GRANT
RECONSIDERATION ON ALL BILLS IF
THEY FAIL. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. SOMEBODY MEMBER. WHEN
YOU'RE READY. AWESOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MEMBERS AB 2620
REDUCES THE NUMBER ON THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
FROM 25 TO 18. AND REQUIRES
COMMISSIONERS TO HAVE
PROFESSIONAL, LIVED OR ACADEMIC
EXPERTISE RELATED TO AGING. IT
ALSO DEFINES THE COMMISSION AS
AN ADVISORY BODY RELATING TO THE
BAGLEY-KEENE OPEN MEETING ACT,
AND ALLOWS THE COMMISSION TO
ENGAGE IN FEDERAL ADVOCACY
EFFORTS. THE COMMISSION HAS HAD
A STATUTORY COMPOSITION OF 25
MEMBERS SINCE ITS INCEPTION.
DURING ITS EXISTENCE, IT HAS
NEVER HAD ALL COMMISSION SEATS
APPOINTED. HOWEVER, QUORUM IS
DICTATED BY THE NUMBER OF THOSE
COMPRISED TO SERVE, INCLUDING
VACANCIES, MAKING IT DIFFICULT
TO CONDUCT BUSINESS BY REDUCING
THE NUMBER OF SERVING
COMMISSIONERS. ALLOWS THE
COMMISSION TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND CONDUCT
BUSINESS, AND REQUIRING
EXPERTISE RELATED TO AGING FOR
ALL FUTURE APPOINTEES ALLOWS FOR
MORE MEANINGFUL ADVOCACY MOVING
FORWARD. REDEFINING THE
COMMISSION AS AN ADVISORY BODY
ALLOWS FOR FLEXIBILITY IN THE
WAYS IN WHICH COMMISSIONERS MAY
PARTICIPATE IN MEETINGS, AND
WILL LIKELY ALLOW FOR MORE
GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY ON THE
COMMISSION. WITH ME TODAY IS
RITA SIGNS, FORMER COMMISSIONER
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
AGING AND THE SPONSOR OF AB
2620. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
MY NAME IS RITA. SIGNS. I'M HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF H.R. 2620.
AS WAS SAID, I AM A FORMER
MEMBER OF THE COMMISSION, HAVING
SERVED THREE TERMS. I'VE RUN
THREE DEPARTMENTS FOR THE STATE
AND WAS THE APPOINTMENT
SECRETARY IN THE FIRST
ADMINISTRATION, JEFF, JERRY
BROWN'S. SO I THINK THE
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT THIS BILL
DOES HAS IS VERY CLEAR, THE ONLY
OTHER THING THAT I WOULD ADD TO
IT IS THAT IT, IT ELIMINATES
LANGUAGE FOR OBSOLETE DUTIES
THAT THE COMMISSION FORMERLY
OPERATED UNDER, THE, IT WAS
CALLED. IT'S BEEN SO LONG, IT
WAS CALLED THE STATEWIDE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATES THAT WAS
UNDER THE COMMISSION THERE, A
COMPLETELY SEPARATE ORGANIZATION
NOW KNOWN AS THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE. AND WE ARE
HERE ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
WELL, WELL, THANK YOU. YOU KNOW,
I SAY JUST BECAUSE WE GIVE YOU
TWO MINUTES DOESN'T MEAN YOU
NEED TO USE THEM IF WE CAN. YOU
KNOW. VERY GOOD, ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SHOW THEIR
SUPPORT, PLEASE COME FORWARD
WITH YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION. JASON GEPHARDT
WITH THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL NOW
GIVE TIME TO ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION AS A LEAD WITNESS
THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE HEARD.
OKAY. SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT. WE WILL BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE, SENATOR, BLAKE SPEAR,
THANK YOU. THIS SEEMS LIKE A
GREAT BILL. AND IT'S SO RARE
WHEN THERE'S SUBTRACTION INSTEAD
OF ADDITION, AND SO I APPLAUD
YOU FOR THINKING OF THAT. AND I
HOPE THAT IT DOES LEAD TO MORE
OF A QUORUM. I MEAN, MORE
FREQUENT QUORUMS AND ALSO THE
ABILITY FOR MORE PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE. SO, I THINK IT'S A
GREAT BILL, AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT AND MOVE WHEN
APPROPRIATE. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR.
SENATOR TROBO. YES. SO PHÐ,
THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL. AND I
ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM SENATOR
BLAKE'S FEAR, QUITE, QUITE TRUE
ON THAT END, BUT ALSO, I ALSO
WANTED TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY,
SINCE WE HAVE MISS DIRECTOR
SIGNS HERE, MY COLLEAGUES MAY OR
MAY NOT KNOW THAT DIRECTOR
SCIENCE ACTUALLY WAS, THE
DIRECTOR OF ED FOR A YEAR, RIGHT
AFTER THE PANDEMIC. DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WE ARE AMONGST ROYALTY
AND I. AND I WANT TO JUST
PUBLICLY THANK HER FOR STEPPING
UP FOR THAT IMMENSE DUTY THAT I
WAS VERY, VERY DIFFICULT. I'M
SURE DURING THAT TIME AND I ALL
MY COLLEAGUES ARE NEW, WE'RE NOT
AT THE AT THE, YOU'RE SO LUCKY
SENATE. BUT I JUST WANTED TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT WORK AND, THE
COMMENTS AND WHY IT TAKES SO
MUCH, VALUE IN WHAT YOU SAY IS
THAT SHE WAS VERY TOUGH WHEN SHE
CAME IN. AND I REMEMBER YOUR
STATEMENTS AND YOUR COMMENTS
WHEN YOU FIRST CAME INTO THE
DEPARTMENT. SO I KNOW THAT WHEN
YOU'RE COMING IN, YOU'RE LOOKING
AT THIS, YOU'RE STUDYING IT FROM
A VERY CRITICAL AND ANALYTICAL
PERSPECTIVE AS TO WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE IN, ON, IN THIS
COMMISSION. SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED SERVICE AND WORK,
IN YOUR ADVOCACY. AND THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR YOUR ACKNOWLEDGMENT AS AS
THE ASSEMBLYWOMAN SAID, THIS
COMMISSION HAS NEVER HAD 25
MEMBERS. SO WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
BE MUCH MORE EFFICIENT AND MUCH
MORE COST EFFECTIVE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BANES, I JUST
WANT TO SAY, YOU KNOW, AS AS
CHAIR, WE OFTEN ARE ABLE TO LOOK
AT BILLS AND PUT THEM ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AND YOU DON'T
GET THAT OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLAIN
GOOD POLICY. Kò, THIS WAS AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT SINCE YOU WERE
ON CONSENT AND THE ASSEMBLY, I
REALLY FELT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
HEAR THIS MATTER BECAUSE THERE'S
NOT OFTEN TIMES, AS SENATOR
BLAKE SPEER MENTIONED, THAT WE
RIGHTSIZE GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRACY. AND SO THANK YOU
FOR COMING FORWARD WITH THIS
BILL AND PRESENTING ON THIS,
BECAUSE I THINK WE HAVE A DUTY
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS TO ALSO
SHARE THE GOOD NEWS. SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND
JUST SUCH AN HONOR.
COMMISSIONER. SCIENCE ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE A MOTION, OH, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE, PLEASE, I'M
HONORED TO BE THE CHAIR OF AGING
LONG TERM CARE. AND I'M HONORED
TO BE ABLE TO HELP WITH THIS.
AND LET'S GET BACK TO WORK AND
GET THINGS DONE. SO WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE,
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH, WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR BLAKE SPEER,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB 2620. ALVARADO, GIL.
AYE. ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. AYE.
CHO BOGUE. AYE. OKOBOJI. BLAKE.
SPEER I BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
HURTADO. MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR AYE.
WE HAVE EYES! FOUR ZERO NOES! WE
WILL PUT THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
SO I WILL MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT.
IT IS NOW 445. WE WILL HOLD THE
CALL OPEN IN, OUT OF RESPECT OF
OUR MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE,
PRESENT, READY TO GO. I WILL
MOVE US TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE ONE BILL ON THE PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE. ITEM
EIGHT. ASSEMBLY BILL 2948. DO
ANY MEMBERS WISH TO REMOVE ANY
BILLS FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR?
OKAY. HEARING NONE. WE WILL NOW
TAKE UP THESE BILLS. DO WE HAVE
A MOTION? SO MOVED. MOVED BY
SENATOR OCHOA, BOGH ASSISTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE. ITEM
EIGHT AB 2948 CONSENT CALENDAR.
MOTION IS Dð. PASS TO JUDICIARY
WITH A RECOMMENDATION TO
CONSENT. ALVARADO. GIL. AYE.
ALVARADO GIL. AYE. OCHOA. BOGUE.
AYE. AKABOGU. AYE BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. HURTADO
MENGIBAR. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
ISAAC FOUR. NO. ZERO, WE'LL PUT
THAT, PUT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ON CALL AS WELL. SO WE'RE GOING
TO DO ONE RUN THROUGH. WE'LL
LIFT THE CALL AND DO ONE RUN
THROUGH, AND THEN WE WILL DO A
SECOND RUN THROUGH AT 5:00 TO
ALLOW FOR ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO BE PRESENT. SO,
ASSISTANT, PLEASE LIFT THE CALL.
FILE ITEM ONE ON AB 866 ALVARADO
GIL. NOT VOTING AKABOGU. BLAKE.
SPEER. OH OKAY. HURTADO. JUST
FOR CLARITY, WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLL. ONE MORE TIME.
JUST WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL ON ASSEMBLY BILL 866, ITEM
NUMBER ONE. OKAY, SO THAT WAS
HURTADO. OKAY ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. OKAY OKAY. GOT IT. OKAY
OKAY. AB 922 HURTADO. FILE ITEM
SIX. AB 2477. HURTADO. FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB 2620. HURTADO. CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
2948. HURTADO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR JOINING US TODAY.
WE WILL KEEP THE CALL OPEN UNTIL
5:00. AT THAT TIME, WE'LL LIFT
THE CALL AND WE WILL GAVEL OUT.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
AND THAT WILL GO TO RECESS UNTIL
5:00. PLEASE.
THANK YOU. WE'LL NOW RESUME. THE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE WILL
NOW RESUME IN ROOM 2200. THIS IS
THEIR FINAL CALL, WE HAVE THE
FOUR BILLS ON CALL, IF ANY
MEMBERS ARE IN THE BUILDING THAT
WOULD LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN
VOTE, PLEASE RETURN TO THE
HEARING ROOM IMMEDIATELY SO WE
CAN FINISH LIFTING OUR CALLS
WITHOUT DELAY, UPON REVIEW OF
THE BILLS THAT ARE IN FRONT OF
US TODAY, WE DO HAVE ONE THAT IS
DOUBLE REFERRED, AND I WOULD
LIKE TO, AS CHAIR, TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO, TO VOTE ON
ASSEMBLY BILL, ITEM NUMBER ONE,
ASSEMBLY BILL 866. RUBIO, WHEN
APPROPRIATE. OKAY. ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT. WE WILL LIFT THE
CALL. ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS. HURTADO
FILE ITEM ONE AB 866. HURTADO
OH. ALVARADO, GIL Ã. ALVARADO.
GIL. AYE THAT IS FOUR EYES AND
ZERO KNOWS THAT BILL IS OUT. I'M
SORRY. THREE EYES AND ONE. NO.
THAT BILL IS OUT. CAN YOU SAY
WHERE THE Dð PASSES SO THAT WE
KNOW WHERE IT'S GOING FIRST?
RIGHT. FILE ITEM ONE, AB 866. DO
PASS TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
RIGHT? RIGHT. WITH THREE EYES
AND ONE. NO, NO, THAT BILL IS
OUT. OKAY. FILE ITEM TWO AB 922.
ALVARADO GIL. NOT VOTING.
HURTADO THAT BILL HAS TWO EYES
AND ONE. NO. THAT BILL FAILS,
AND WE WILL ALLOW
RECONSIDERATION. THAT BILL IS
OUT. OKAY. FILE ITEM. SEVEN AB
2620. HURTADO. ALL RIGHT. WE
HAVE I CAN'T SEE. SORRY, SORRY.
WE HAVE FOUR EYES. ZERO KNOWS
THAT BILL IS OUT. CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEM EIGHT.
HURTADO ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE FOUR
EYES THAT BILL, CONSENT CALENDAR
PASSES THAT AND THAT IS OUT.
CAN'T CALL ANYMORE BECAUSE
ALREADY YOU ALREADY PUT IT ON.
THAT'S WHAT I TOLD HER, BUT SHE
SAID I COULDN'T. BUT THEN, LIKE
I SAID, THAT'S WHAT I SAID. AS I
SAID, I'M CONFUSED.
FILE ITEM SIX AB 2477. HURTADO
OKAY. THERE'S FOUR EYES. ZERO
KNOWS THAT BILL PASSES AND THAT
BILL IS OUT. RIGHT. I WANT TO
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF. AND THANK YOU FOR ALL FOR
BEING HERE TODAY, THE COMMITTEE
ON SENATE HUMAN SERVICES IS NOW
ADJOURNED.